[Music]
all right
i'm going live a little bit early
because we have
a lot of questions and there's no sense
me just
sitting around for five minutes doing
nothing while the questions are
pouring in and actually to answer the
very first one
i went and got myself a few props out of
the library
so first question gutter grown what
resources did you use to teach yourself
latin so let me say from the beginning
people often ask me about you know latin
greek german
things along those lines and i would not
suggest trying to learn languages the
way that i did in part because i did
things in very
strange ways that worked out for me but
probably wouldn't work out necessarily
for everybody else
and i'm also when it comes to
understanding language as kind of a
systems
person i don't like doing a lot of
memorization for memorization's sake i
like to understand how languages
function
as a system so
i'll start by saying this i first
started learning latin
in a very low level when i was in sixth
and seventh grade
and that's because i went to university
lake school which
was a private school that i got a
scholarship to
and my parents wanted me there because
um
you know the the public elementary and
middle and high schools were not very
good where
i was growing up we grew up out in the
countryside
and they just didn't have a lot of
resources and so i went there
and i learned a lot of stuff at us
there's a lot of story i could tell
about that maybe i'll do that sadler's
stories
because most of the kids there were very
rich
and very few of them were particularly
smart so i got to see how class dynamics
worked
uh close up but i did get to study latin
and so you know i learned basic stuff
like in the first
year i think even by like the second
year we'd only learned two declensions
you know
and we didn't really learn much of the
conjugations or anything like that
i think we may have been introduced to
the third declension by then
but you know most of the kids were
really struggling with the class and i
was
i was kind of screwing off in the class
so drop that
and then fast forward about
well how long would it be so when i left
eighth grade i would have been
13 and then i started studying latin
when i was in graduate school and
i did it i started uh my first year
there so that would be
i was uh 25 yeah
so 12 years in between and
i started i had an army field manual
that was for
um jag officers and
i started using that it was like a teach
yourself latin thing for
for people to learn enough latin to be
able to read texts that they they needed
to do for
for the army and so i worked my way
through that and then i was like well
that's cool you know i think i have a
good sense of latin
now i knew that because i'd already you
know
learned french and german that one of
the things you do is you go on to start
you leave behind the study of the
language as such and you read text
you read authors and try to
gain some vocabulary that way and get to
see the language you could say in the
wild you know
so i went and i got from the uh
the library at southern illinois
university a copy of this book
cicero's uh academia and this is the low
version where it got the latin
and i thought well i should be able to
read cicero now no
it took me an entire semester to get
through
reading 10 pages of the academia and i
was like wow this is this is difficult
stuff
so then i i thought about okay what are
the people actually learning
latin doing and i you know they had like
the wheel lock
stuff there as textbooks and i was like
well i don't need that crap i already
i've already like learned a lot what i
really need is the reference
book that they have alan and greeno's
new latin grammar
and um it's probably not new anymore
right
this is an amazing book it's got like
all these amazing discussions
uh broken down into sections about all
the different
stuff that's going on in the language
and it also connects it with
indo-european linguistics so there's
comparative stuff between that
and what's going on in proto german
and what's going on in greek and
sanskrit
and all of that so i i found this
fascinating
and i took a year and you know a couple
hours a day i worked through
sections of this this grammar book and
looked at every single example that they
provided
and then i was like okay now i'm going
to come back to
reading texts so
one of the first texts aquinas is some
mateo logiai
in this you know latin english uh
you know latin on one side english on
the other version which is very nice to
have sometimes the english translations
aren't very good especially the ones by
anthony kennedy
believe it or not uh because he sort of
like turns
aquinas into an analytic philosopher but
often they're they're interesting
and aquinas wrote deliberately in a
simple latin because the believe it or
not the somatiologia
is supposed to be a book for beginners
it's not meant to be like advanced
studies
and so you know i worked through that
and then i was like well i need
something a bit more challenging
and that's how i got into anselm reading
anselm's prosologian
in latin i was like holy crap there's a
lot of cool stuff going on here
and i kind of like the way that he he
uses the language itself
and then after that it was just you know
like um you know doing
one thing or another um you know i got
involved with the aquinas translation
project
translating uh the commentary on the
psalms the last book that he was working
on
at the time that he died uh along with
the somatologia
uh tertium parse um
territory up harsh right and then um you
know i started reading other authors as
well and
and that's that's basically it so i
don't know that that path would be
all that useful it's rather
idiosyncratic isn't it
i don't know that that would be that
helpful for for others and i don't know
about other resources to
teach yourself latin because i don't i
don't need to use any other resources
because i'm
i'm not at that that point so it's not
something that i
specialize in helping other people learn
languages that would be a great thing
for somebody who's like a contemporary
latin teacher all right next question
from mark glad to see you here mark how
am i doing how are all the classes going
am i excited for stoicon x
so i'll i'll do the first two
um i'm doing okay you know i'm teaching
six different classes this semester
some of which involve producing new
video content
so i have shot probably over a hundred
new videos for my my different classes
uh already this at this point in the
semester i'll probably be you know
around 300 by the time that i'm done
i've got a medical ethics class a
business ethics class
a straight out normal ethics class intro
to philosophy
existentialist philosophy and literature
and
world religions and so world religions
and biomedical ethics i'm shooting a lot
of video content for those classes
shooting more existentialist stuff for
existentialism
not too much new stuff for for business
ethics or ethics or intro to philosophy
there i'm kind of relying on the catalog
that i've built up already but i did
shoot some new
business ethics content about virtue
ethics and so you know i'm
like super busy we've also had some
illnesses here and so that you know
makes things tough
a little bit you know wednesday last
week i was not not this
this last week the week before that i
was like so out of it i had to cancel
all my
client meetings and classes because i
think i i i'm not even sure what i was
saying to people i was probably kind of
delirious
but things are things are good you know
it's it's fall here now
beautiful time of year got to see my
daughter yesterday who
took the bus down from university of
wisconsin-milwaukee
down here to the to she went past the
downtown she was in the neighborhood
south of us so i took a walk out there
and
and got to chitchat with her a bit and
meet some of her
you know people in her program who came
along with her and
that's always nice so you know i'd say
things are pretty good
you know and we are heading into this
stoic uh
season there are there's the big stoicon
coming up which i'm an on-deck speaker
for
and doing a lot of behind the scenes
things there's stoic week and then
there's all the stoic on x's
coming up including one that we are
doing i'm speaking in two others
uh the stoichiomex new england next week
and
uh stoic salon which is sometime in
november i believe so
so a lot of stuff going on you know
all right uh matthew has a stoic related
question
um myself and a friend have been using
your videos on the stoics to back up our
self-directed study
we're interested to know your thoughts
and how stoicism intersects with
christian thought
so it that's a complicated topic um
there is
no really simple way to
to express that um a lot of people think
that that stoicism
and you know other philosophies like
epicureanism just kind of went away
because christianity
came on the scene and came to dominate
thought and that is totally not the case
once you start actually looking into the
history of thought
for a variety of reasons so i'll just
lay out a few of these but you could
probably write a whole book
tracing out these things and as a matter
of fact some books
have been written you know um
what is it blanking on her first name
coalish i want to say martha but i don't
know that that's right
um she has a great book on stoicism in
the middle ages
because the monks were reading stoic
literature
and transmitting it but here's here's
what we can say
so the first thing to keep in mind
is that christianity emerges
within a greco-roman culture that has
already been
in formation for a very long time is not
a monolithic thing by the way the people
who are like i love ancient greece i
love ancient rome
usually they don't know the hell they're
talking about you know they if they
showed up
they would have been ostracized or
kicked out or enslaved
right away um we're talking about like
the real
greco-roman culture which was a mishmash
of lots of different things going on you
know
and it wasn't just about big five
philosophies or anything like that
schools of rhetoric were competing
medical schools were competing
there's lots of different things
happening culturally
and you can say that stoicism as a
school was was a big
an important school but one of the key
things
that you see in hellenistic and then
later ancient philosophy
is eclecticism the willingness
and syncretism the willingness to take
ideas from other people
and adapt them this is big in middle
stoicism where
posidonius and peneteus are actually
incorporating things from the platonic
or aristotelian points of view
this is big even in with chrysippus who
is reacting to the academic skeptics and
the epicureans
and you know what's left of the the
aristotelians at the time
and you can see a similar thing with
neoplatonism
neoplatonism which was a major movement
in philosophy
um used aristotelianism or stoicism or a
combination of both
sort of as a basis for a lot of what
they're doing and then they would have
platonic conceptions sort of on top of
that
great example simplicius his commentary
on epictetus is uncoridion which is a
really cool work
is framing epictetus and stoicism within
a neoplatonic perspective
so neoplatonism winds up being one of
the main
you could say vectors of early christian
thought right there are
pagan neoplatonists like um platinus
and you know proclass there are jewish
neoplatonists
arguably field of alexandria would fit
into that
there are christian neoplatons who are
many of the church fathers right
so they know stoicism you'll find
clement of alexandria
using some stoic thought incorporating
it into his ideas sometimes pushing
off against it lactose on uh in
discussing the anger of god we'll
we'll actually talk about all the
different ancient philosophical schools
and then why christianity
uh you know sort of adds something
better to the mix
and so stoic thought along with other
thought was was incorporated into early
christian thought
and we can also talk about practices as
well
monasticism which really had its
uh sort of hardcore interpretations in
palestine and even more in egypt
drew upon neoplatonic thought and drew
upon
stoic thought so you know there's
a great argument for how the eight
thoughts of um uh
inaudible are really
similar to what's going on in stoicism
this is a case made by margaret graver
of course you know that from the eight
thoughts we get eight capital vices
in john cassian major monastic writer of
the west
um very important among benedictines
these become under gregory
the great the guy i'm named after in his
moralia
on job the seven deadly sins so there's
there's all these interesting vectors
and as i was mentioning
you know the the the monks um
are preserving cicero and seneca and
a little bit of epictetus and you know
writing this stuff out and thinking
about it um
also uh another another um
key thing would be boethius who knew a
lot about stoicism
and they you know they read his works
augustine talks about the stoics at
various points so
stoicism never completely disappeared
but it was it was no longer like an
independent school and so there are all
these different important influences
well into the middle ages then with the
revival of stoicism
as something that you could study in the
renaissance and
in the early modern period stoicism was
a school that was
you know there were some people who
tried to fuse that and christianity
together in neo-stoicism
there were many others who who you know
looked at stoicism as a viable school
there's stoicism is a big influence on
arguably christian philosophers like
rene descartes you know there's there's
important aspects of stoicism i mean he
and
princess elizabeth actually in their
correspondence discuss seneca
so so you know there there's there's
quite a bit of stoic stuff
there um you know if you're considering
stoicism
as a system of thought and christianity
despite the overlaps there are going to
be some places where you got to like you
know well i'm going to go this way or
i'm going to go this way so
you can't say they're exactly the same
thing but there's a lot of interesting
overlaps and compatibilities so
all right let's take the next one dale
says how can i have confidence in my
views considering the vast amount of
work published on both sides of almost
every idea especially if i'm not a
philosopher well it gets even worse it's
not on both sides
because both sides is usually a
simplistic way of representing it
usually there's multiple sides
when you start digging into it how can
you have confidence in your views you
just you know
keep working at it and try to arrive at
the best views that you can
sometimes you you know you're gonna have
experiences where you're like wow man i
was so off about that
back then and now i've got better
viewpoints on this or that um
and uh you know you don't have to like
boil the ocean you don't have to know
every single thing nobody does i mean
people have said that like hegel was the
last person who could have a systematic
view
of all of the sciences and and
humanities of his time i don't think he
even
even had it quite frankly you don't have
to
you know there isn't this this absolute
need to have read everybody
um in order to be on point about some
things because some of this we look
for confirmation within our life
and you know you don't have to you don't
have to read stuff that you don't find
particularly interesting
or helpful there's no duty to be a
philosopher i would say and even the
people who are doing academic philosophy
most of them are so hyper-specialized
that they don't they don't know very
much outside of their their little field
so i wouldn't i wouldn't feel too bad
about that
uh johann can you explain some
difference and similarities between
blondels and dairy does projects and
readings of philosophical figures
yeah so let's start with derrida first
um
derrida his early work is
is it's not systematic as such but it's
very rigorous
and you know what deconstruction
basically comes down to
in its early stuff is like saying we're
going to like totally look at what this
person has to say
i'm going can read everything that the
person has written and then like look
for where the
contradictions arise either
contradictions between
text which is what a traditional
historian of philosophy does anyway
right
you know you look for like well
descartes says this over here he says
this over here can we reconcile these
um but you also look for like where for
example you know plato
talking about why speech is better than
writing
in the phaedrus wait a second plato
you're doing writing right
deconstruction focuses in on those
sorts of things and it also is
anti-totalizing meaning that we can we
can't arrive at a perspective that is
like the single
perspective that encompasses everything
and you know those sort of things
actually should be rather
non-controversial for anybody who's a
serious thinker about
philosophy or pays attention to what's
going on in philosophical texts
but you know there's a lot of people who
resist those those sort of insights in
his middle period
um derrida you know became a star
and he was still doing occasionally good
rigorous work but a lot of the stuff
that he writes i think is actually not
worth reading or spending time on
um quite frankly and the only people are
going to be reading you know
say gla you know a hundred years from
now are like dairy dust scholars and
there'll be a tiny little segment of
weirdos over there in the corner
but i think on-gram mythology will still
be read 100 years from now
um and then the later period uh
you know i mean so the middle period
dario's method is let's see what i can
get away with in terms of puns and
playing around with language
and then he becomes serious again in the
the his his final period
where you find like the gift of death or
the politics of friendship where he's
becoming like
seriously aware that there's some crises
and issues looming like the immigrant
crisis
um dario is one of the first people to
to be really devoting a lot of serious
attention to that from a philosophical
perspective in
politics of friendship or specters of
marx and those you know
he's he's doing his his usual stick i
don't really like
his his bombastic claims about how
deconstruction is democracy is this is
that i think he should have stuck with
it as just being kind of a
a method and then a bit more humble but
i'm not darida so
you know now blondel about you know
well starting uh not quite a hundred
years before darida about 90
i guess you could say 1893 no
a little bit a little bit further than
that right maybe maybe 70.
um blondel is a is a catholic thinker
who is um struggling to take
you know um sort of a cognizance of of
the history of thought
and approaching things as he calls it
dialectically it's not the same thing as
a hegelian dialectic
uh or the marxist or the kierkegaardian
or whatever
and he's he's the same sort of person
where he'll read everything that
somebody wrote because you of course
obviously want to understand the person
and then you start
you know you sort of like he calls it
the method of charity
you extend a complete like well
this stuff could be true to them and
then you see what happens when you do
that
and when you do that you find that a lot
of philosophies almost like turn
themselves inside out
so he's doing something similar to
deconstruction
but with a different aim in mind an aim
of
providing a philosophy that would be
totally adequate to the the requirements
of philosophy
which is an ongoing process and totally
uh
you know fulfilling the exigencies as he
called them of christianity
gary dad doesn't have any sort of
overtly theological project
project like that and is actually very
suspicious of that until his later works
and so those are those are some
important uh distinctions i'd say
all right uh adwin asks i was wondering
if you would watch a philosophy program
made for bbc
maybe i don't know i mean most
philosophy programs are usually crap
because they uh
they they have to like they're made to
like appeal to the masses
and for some reason they think that the
masses are stupid and are more
interested in hearing you know um
bombastic you know hyperbolic takes
about philosophers than careful
discussion about them i suppose because
it's less dramatic you know
so i i don't know that they would be any
good
um the other problem with the bbc tends
to be that they they only
like so many other places they only like
seek out the big name
famous hosts you know they're not gonna
like look for like
so let's say they're doing something on
on um thomas hobbs
they're they're gonna go find some
oxfordy person
who may be a good scholar on on hubs
or may just happen to be like somebody
who knows the producer
and went to school with them and all
that that's the same thing for american
productions as well
um but you know they could get over that
they could produce a good show i don't
know it would depend on the show
you know i'm not quite sure why
there's a question about that all right
uh kierkegaardian dude what do you think
about social conservative americans
concerned about religious liberty who
think that the nomination of
conservative judges justices like amy
coney barrett is a silver lining and
otherwise disastrous presidency
i'd say that they're you know they're
they're 20 years behind in their
thinking
and that they should have realized that
the republicans have suckered in
uh social conservative americans and
used them for years and years and years
and they're never going to give you any
of the stuff that you actually want
they're just a bunch of people
interested in holding onto power they'll
say anything whatsoever
or they're complete ideologues and when
it comes to like
you know amy coney barrett she belongs
to a cult
i don't know why people don't get this
if you are an actual conservative you do
not want a cultist
in charge of anything because you want
to conserve things
you want to keep things in play the
people of praise i know the reamers
adrian
uh you know he's the one who was quoted
in the new york times article and marie
i've had conversations with them about
this very group
they are not mainstream you know the
group that that barrett belongs to not
mainstream catholics
it is not anti-catholic to say that
they're a cult
so if that's the devil's bargain that
you want to make in order to
get something in the supreme court i
think that's foolish
and foolish from a philosophical
perspective it's the opposite of wisdom
um you know for for a very long time you
know the republicans
i've seen this myself because you know
i've been observing
these things sort of within and without
i used to go to all these notre dame
center for ethics and cultures
conferences where a lot of these
important discussions were happening
um this whole stuff about we're going to
nominate these these justices
terrible argument you know you look at
the damage
that that party has been doing i'm not
by the way letting the democrats off the
hook
but the republicans at this point in
time are definitely the worst party
and have done way more damage to it to
this society
than anyone else so if you're a
conservative i would say you can't
actually vote republican
um you need to find a third party or
stay home
or do something else you know
or you know or vote for the the
democrats just to get the republicans
out
and and tell them that they need to
reform their their stuff
so i'm very unsympathetic to that notion
that that somehow she would be
a silver lining otherwise disastrous
presidency
and in part because of you know the the
people of praise thing too
so all right uh it just jumped a little
bit looks like we have a lot of
questions
um jesse asks in a hegel core concept
video
i describe the girda desire or hunger
where you act upon it removing its
independence you probably mean the
independence of the object right
is this just present in hegel's idea of
bhagira or partly in the german word
itself
it's not it's not necessarily the german
word itself hegel is defining what
desire
does what desire is um
and he's he's interested in the
independence thing so that's that's not
it's not inherent in the very word it's
just
how it is all right um
darko polo says which of the
pre-industrial philosophers
do i think would be the most shocked
about the state of the world today in
terms of population civilization
environment nature i don't know i mean
i don't know how you would how you would
um say which would be most
shocked uh we'd have to know something
about their
psychology in order to to say that and i
don't i don't know that we
we can actually predict that sort of
stuff and you're you're asking about a
lot of different things population
civilization environment nature
might be that some of them would be more
shocked about you know the population
some would be more shocked about
civilization or lack thereof some would
be you know
uh shocked about the environment some
would be shocked about technology i i
don't
i don't know how we could how he could
say who would uh
be most chris meyer the so-called
neoplatonus i don't know why you'd say
so-called because that's what we call
them
worth spending time on yeah of course
they are so
everybody is worth spending time on um
so are the stoics so are the skeptics so
are
uh galen you know somebody who's not
really a philosopher such but a medical
writer lots of philosophy and his stuff
so
yeah um i mean platinus is the is the
big heavy hitter right
as i mentioned a lot of the church
fathers are themselves
essentially coming from a neoplatonous
perspective a christian nail platonus
perspective
arguably augustine and boethius are as
well
right um so and then there's all these
other
you know people like proclass and um
there's also these interesting people
that are middle
slash neoplatonists like like if i
remember ammonius
um but you know you can find a good
history of philosophy that'll
clue you into them the big big guy of
course is platinus
but there's a lot of other really great
um
neoplatonist authors i mentioned some
plikias as one
who are definitely worth reading uh
anupam says i i learned that sarah ahmed
is queering the herserlian subsumption
of embroidered
embodied historicality by a disembodied
phenomenology what does it mean in
simple language
i don't know i don't read her so
um i don't read everybody who's out
there and cutting edge
that would be a good question for
somebody who has some sort of connection
to her
oh here's a good one from andrew
what did rilka mean when he said love is
two solitudes coming together
so he didn't really just say that two
solitudes coming together
and protecting each other is is a key
part of it as well
and recognizing each other so rilka
thinks
that within all of us there is this
dimension of interiority
which is not pure interiority because it
is also connected with
the you know the world that we're in and
it's things and it's people and animals
and nature
and also what he calls the big things
like death
and we all have this capacity to develop
this dimension within ourselves so he
speaks of building your solitude or
expanding your solitude this is you know
for example in letters to
a young poet when he's talking to the
young military officer who wants to be
an artist of some sort a creative type
so in i think it's in letter seven or
letter eight he's talking about
love and he says that most young people
haven't sufficiently developed that
dimension within themselves and they try
to give themselves to the other
and it's just a hot mess it's screwed up
because they haven't
adequately developed their themselves as
as beings
and this is his ideal for what love
would be
two solitudes two people who have
developed that dimension within
themselves
and are not expending expecting to like
have a fusion where i'm one with the
other
or any other sort of romantic nonsense
but rather are able to recognize each
other
and there's a certain respect there but
also a certain desire
and a companionship
and i think he's completely right about
that it's not realized by many people
in part because we we pitch again as
rilka points out we pitched so many
stupid conventional ideas about what
love is
and um people buy into those to their
detriment
and instead of like developing as
you know fully close to their potential
being actualized
human beings they they offer each other
kind of caricatures
so love is two solitudes you know
bordering and protecting each other
and uh you could say interpenetrating to
some degree but not
not where one loses oneself and the
other
all right um
elijah says do you agree with heidegger
that although he regards hegel's system
as the most powerful thought of modern
times and completion of metaphysics
which he doesn't
he thinks god in spirit must be thought
pre-subjective
um he views hegel's you know
he views hegel's making an important
contributions bringing history into the
picture
nietzsche is the last metaphysician
according to heidegger
so hegel is not the last metaphysician
and he is putting forth a
new view on being and beings
but it's an ultimately mistaken one as
well just like plato was and just like
the
medieval christian thinkers were so
yeah rima what do you think about
gatomer gatomer is an interesting guy
um you know for those who don't know
hans georg gottamer
student of heidegger one of the people
big and hermeneutics
well worth reading um he's actually got
some interesting
pieces on hegel and on plato he and paul
record paul recur in the french
sphere um we're working on kind of
similar stuff
using some of the same figures i would
say
not too many people talk about gautama
these days which is kind of a shame
i like him um but
by the time that i was in graduate
school he was kind of considered to be
like
you know not cutting edge anymore which
is really a shame the philosophy is way
too given to like fads and cutting edge
and stuff like that
all right uh tyson what are your
thoughts on phds in education well
education is my passion i've not seen
the rigor and seriousness in this field
that i see in
philosophy and linguistics so i i can't
generalize across the board because
obviously i haven't looked at every
single you know
phd in education or educational
leadership
is often what you get your degree in but
i would agree with your assessment that
it's often not very rigorous
they you know these are these are
degrees that were created
to make money for colleges and to give
administrators an extra set of initials
so that they could have social prestige
and justify
higher paychecks um i haven't i'll tell
you this
every master's in doctoral program in
education that i've come across
i've not been impressed with but i
haven't seen that many you know
um i i kind of think that but then again
you can say you know like linguistics
and philosophy
there's a lot of dud phd programs out
there in philosophy as well
i don't know about linguistics because i
haven't ever looked into that but
there's plenty of places where i
wouldn't send a student
um but yeah i mean they're kind of a
made-up degree um
i would say a lot of the stuff that that
is worthwhile in it is probably going to
be taught in other areas as well
um but you know again
i got to be a little careful i don't
really know that that well
that area um
zeno would it matter if god exists or
not depends on how you think of god
i mean like the epicureans who thought
that the gods existed
but were blessed because they had no
involvement in human life you could
probably do without those gods
right pascal accused descartes
of using god early in his philosophy to
get everything started and then not
having any use for him later on
probably accurate you know um so it
really depends on what conception of god
you have i mean if you have
an exception of uh they call it a deus
oteosus a god who doesn't do anything
i'm not sure why you need that if you
have a conception of a god
who actually cares about human beings
and somehow intervenes in things
that probably would make a difference
right so yeah
uh good numb how to get out of absolute
uninterestedness
i don't think such a thing exists but
you might say
that what you're talking about there in
a hyperbolic way is like being
generally uninterested in things i don't
know that there's a way to do that
other than like finding something that
you're interested in it probably
requires you to not
you know immediately dismiss things and
to give them a little bit of um
you know leeway you could say and to
extend yourself into them
but i don't know i don't know
other than just like finding something
that that trips your trigger as we used
to say
that may be um
[Music]
you know what you have to do all right
ben
just started your half hour hegel series
really enjoying it section four the
preface hegel talks about the
substantial life is this similar to
sart's idea of bad
faith no i wouldn't say so um
bad faith involves a deception of
oneself about whether one is deceiving
uh it's sort of an unstable thing you
know
substantial life i mean sartre could say
that that's bad faith but i don't think
hegel would agree with him on that
um bruno why do i consider kierkegaard
to be a great philosopher what's great
about his concept of anxiety
um well i mean this concept of anxiety
you can see it there in heidegger
and sartre and so many other people
right so
that's good i mean i think that
kierkegaard
is doing some really cool stuff in his
philosophy
and he's you know he's got a great
critique of his contemporary culture
some of which applies to our own
contemporary culture you find that in
things like say the present
age um
he also has a lot of really interesting
you know
portions of his works where maybe you
don't buy into the whole thing but
you're like wow this is a this is a
great insight right here
and um i would say that you know
among christian thinkers he is one who
is really thinking
out what the conditions would be for the
eternal
to make its appearance in in
time and in humanity
within a culture that already is
thinking in terms of universals and
stuff like that the other thing i really
like about his work is that
he you know when you read through him he
really does
have a lot of grasps on different
ways of being a human being you know
um so that i mean that's probably enough
about kierkegaard i probably should do
more writing about him because i do
enjoy
that and i've got a few conference
papers that i've never
turned into articles
james should all journal articles be
open access will this help philosophers
connect to the public it will not help
philosophers connect to the public at
all because most philosophers are shitty
writers
and quite frankly not particularly good
thinkers
so making things open access isn't
automatically going to do that
maybe over time it would do that but
academics
if they want to reach the general public
academics need to learn how to write in
ways that can actually meet the general
public doesn't mean you have to dumb
everything down
or put it into listicles or life hacks
or
that sort of nonsense but you do have to
be able to like reach a general audience
rather than just
the you know four peers of yours who are
going to read the article
um should journals be open access
um i don't i don't think that they all
necessarily have to be open access
but they sure they sure shouldn't all be
owned by massive companies that
that make tons and tons of money and
don't pay
the writers anything and that
set up big um roadblocks to other people
getting access to the stuff i think
that's bad
right so companies like elsevier
um i think are predatory companies it's
unfortunate that we've we've done so
much you know
sort of deregulation that we've allowed
companies to to monopolize these these
things
but i don't i don't know how we get away
from this
you know i mean anybody who wants to
start a journal concerted journal maybe
part of the problem is this this whole
notion of prestige
like in philosophy different you know
different journals are ranked at
different levels all those rankings are
[ __ ]
they don't they don't reflect the
quality of the articles what they
reflect is a
parochial little group of people over
here who think that they're the hot [ __ ]
defining what counts as hot [ __ ] and
it's different hot [ __ ] than
the people over here you know um there
are there's really great articles in
obscure journals i mean i know this from
having done my my
research and finding those articles and
being like wow this is amazing stuff
why is it published here well because
that's where the person could get it
published you know
just because you have an article in mind
doesn't mean that it's an actual good
article
or pick whatever other thing you like so
yeah um
let's see here
did i miss one uh yeah i missed one in
here
have i read mock shaler and emanuel
levinos do i see any similarities with
their work both are different
phenomenologists having different
backgrounds
um yeah i've i've actually i mean i
i translated one of shaler's works never
published the translation
or katniss and arbeit one of my
classmates
ended up publishing it later on and he
used some of my
my uh manuscript to help him out um so
yeah i've known shayler for a very long
time
and i've been teaching him
for a very long time as well levine i
saw of course i knew because loving us
was was really big stuff when i was in
grad school and then there were
levanosians were constantly droning on
and on and on about the face of the
other and how we could never do justice
to the other and blah blah blah blah
blah
and my mentor was actually one of the
early translators of levine us
so he brought up levinos in class all
the time in a different way so yeah i
i i'm conversing with those two
and uh you know they're doing different
yeah they're doing different
things um there's some overlap they're
both very interested in ethics
in ways that hysterol and heidegger were
not
um shaler we should remember when we
talk about early phenomenology
a lot of people want to say oh you know
it was it was husserel and then
heidegger and then levinos
with merlot ponte in there that's one
genealogy
mock shaler was as important as husserl
as was heidegger you know and there were
other people who are
equally important as well it wasn't just
this this one single thing
a little bit of a rant of mine because
phenomenologists here in the states
love to ignore you know marcel and
shayla and people like that
um but yeah they're you know they're
both worth reading both worth looking
into
um i prefer shaler to loving us but
that's just me
so uh chris
asks uh i'd like to hear more about
class dynamics in school
well i mean if we're talking about
university like school where i went from
middle school
it was a place uh out in heartland
wisconsin
um it was about a you know 15 minute
drive from where we lived
out on the border of wales and delafield
and
it was you know this is the 1980s
it was a school that at that time went
from sixth grade to high school
classes were quite small we had like 20
kids in my
my class kind of sucked too because
the gender distribution was way off in
my class we had
uh five girls and 15 guys and
you know it was it was uh it had his own
beautiful campus
um it promoted like you know we're all
about academics
i gotta say the academics was kind of
hit and miss
um some of the teachers clearly were not
should not have been teachers um some of
them were were
abusive some of them were just burnt out
um we actually had a
you know we when it came to other things
like athletics
so soccer was really really big at uls
which is cool because i like playing
soccer
we had a former olympian as the coach
that's that's the kind of juice
this place had and you know the the
richies
sent their their kids there the people
that we later on would call the lake set
the people had
houses on the lakes you know and that
was like one of their houses then they'd
have a summer house somewhere else or
things like that and um you know you you
got a
a very clear sense of where you belonged
and it wasn't uh with the rest of the
the kids if you were there on
scholarship
and you couldn't participate effectively
in the the social life that they engaged
in because you know it involved things
like
so i brought this up before here in
wisconsin
skiing was a class distinguisher
if you had money if you were upper
middle class or upper class you went
downhill skiing
except if you were like a kid who lived
near the downhill ski places
then you could go as well and the reason
why
you you had to have money is because it
usually involved a trip
and then a lift ticket which you would
put onto your your jacket and so like
you'd have all these lift tickets to
show that you participated in this thing
skis were expensive you know and it also
involved conspicuous consumption in
other ways like hanging out at the lodge
right
whereas cross-country skiing that was
the common person's thing
so cross-country skiing you could do
anywhere because we had enough snow back
then before global warming
and you could just go to a local park
and maybe you'd have to pay five bucks
for like
a season pass there weren't any tickets
involved
you could rent skis really cheap you
could buy a whole set of skis and boots
and poles for a hundred bucks
you know even less used so
you know those sorts of distinctions
what you wore you know
i wore uh sort of like
cheap stuff that we got at farm and
fleet or target or
wherever they were all wearing designer
clothes you know
and so you you learn about these these
distinctions very
early on and it's it's kind of driven
home to you
um it was also i'll mention a pretty
racist
place pretty sexist place um there are a
lot of things wrong with it as a school
i'm told it's different now but i don't
really know so
that's probably enough about that um
kyle says thomas hobbes lists three
inalienable rights self-defense the
right to resist imprisonment duty not to
endanger oneself in agreements is hob
sovereign truly totalitarian
yes because those rights don't matter
for [ __ ]
you have you have perfect right of
self-defense against a
sovereign who has a complete monopoly on
force
and a complete monopoly on what
doctrines can even be said or taught
it's totalitarian the fact that there's
a few mentions of
rights that you can exercise that aren't
going to do you any damn good
doesn't mean that it's not you know uh
hobbs isn't luck you know
govind says what is what are my thoughts
on dogmatic scientism and the general
population and academia
like any sort of one-sided doctrine it's
uh
you know it's a bad thing it's keeping
people from thinking things through
adequately
making sure they miss large portions of
the world and
fundamentally don't understand
themselves and it it often makes people
into kind of you know crusaders
um and you know yeah there is a good bit
of it in the general population i think
a lot
of that is sort of convenience
you know as soon as people start to like
encounter a major existential life
crisis they might abandon that
academia you find some people like that
as well
uh boomer opinion on the new atheists or
more specifically the four
horsemen i don't take them seriously in
part because i'm you know
a historian of ideas so they're not
there's nothing new about their new
atheism
it's the same old water you know the
same same old stuff as we saw in the
19th century
and even in the enlightenment it's just
gotten a couple new twists to it
you know instead of talking about this
we talk about this
they're not doing anything fundamentally
new and most of their arguments aren't
particularly good
you could still be an atheist and there
could be good reasons for it but you
ain't going to get it from from from
those guys i think
mark says will i comment on the meaning
of plato's allegory of the cave
is this people sticking to the beliefs
they were exposed to growing up without
knowledge of the world
well i mean the the actual context of it
is the allegory of the cave is an
allegory
meant to be a story to illustrate
another story the story of the
philosopher i.e socrates
trying to awaken people to realities
beyond
just what they see here think and not
being taken seriously and then being
killed as a result
that's that's uh one main meaning of it
that's the sort of the original
meaning but then you can make of it
whatever you want you can like say oh
it's the world of today where we're
being fed lies by the media
it's funny too the people who always
talk about being fed lies by the media
it's never the media that they
like so like you know it's always the
mainstream media
but fox news is completely truthful or
it's some other
nonsense flip of that um rather than
considering it all to be
equally shaky um
so you can do it with that you can you
can talk about the sensual world that we
have it's an allegory you can you can
twist it in a lot of different ways you
can even ask questions that go outside
of the allegory like
where do these people get their food you
know what's the deal with those people
behind them do they are they in the know
about this
plato doesn't tell us but we can we can
engage in all sorts of imagination
about that can't we so yeah
uh no idea would you consider yourself
more of a psychoanalyst or schizoid
i'm not one of either so
i'm not i'm not you know when it comes
to duluth i've said that many times
i don't really like the stuff the lose
does with gutari that much i like to
lose by himself
you know so antiochus is not i mean it's
an interesting book it's not it's not
something i think i
really buy much into i think that
delusion is often much more insightful
when he's doing his own thing
and i'm not a psychoanalyst i'll use
some psychoanalytic ideas but
it's not like i belong to a
psychoanalytic school you know
or anything like that i don't think that
these are um your only
possible choices uh so
all right uh idw chungu's thoughts on
nick land and accelerationism don't know
i haven't read nick land
people are always saying uh we want you
to read them
and that reminds me actually there's
somebody on twitter who said they'd send
me a copy of the book
if i give them my address so i gotta go
ahead and take care of that
but i don't um
you know i i read stuff that people will
send me or that i think is particularly
important
um i haven't read fang numina so i can't
really say much
all right um xander do i consider
machiavelli a philosopher
i've heard some philosophy departments
push back against teaching or covering
him
yeah he's a philosopher clearly he's
doing political philosophy
that is a branch of philosophy
don't ever take um a particular group of
philosophers saying that somebody's not
a philosopher
as a verdict
you know like a for philosophy in
general there's many people who take
machiavelli
quite seriously as a philosopher and
they read more than the prince they read
the discourses on livy and some of them
even like
try to get stuff out of his comedy
there's there's huge gaps in most
philosophy departments
i mean people you know won't teach
say alexis to tocqueville who they
should teach um
he's definitely a philosopher but he's
seen as you know like a social theorist
so you go to your poli sci department to
do him or american studies right
and we can say similar things with so
many other people who do deserve to be
taught as philosophers
can sarah do i have a strong view on
hillary putnam as a philosopher i do not
i don't really
care much about hillary putnam kind of a
big deal
when i was in graduate school actually
came to southern illinois
university i didn't find their stuff in
i didn't find his stuff
interesting enough to to really check it
out
all right um
dog heidegger claims concealment and
disclosure are two sides of the same
coin how do you view propaganda i mean
propaganda is is putting forth a
position
and there's going to be some things in
it that it it may
uh you know open up to you
mostly they're going to be garbage and
you know [ __ ] by virtue being
propaganda
but it certainly tells you about the
mindset of the people who are engaging
in it and then there's all sorts of like
sides to it that you can open up and see
what's really there like some you know
deep dark
secrets that are being hashed out or you
know the various lies
going on in there dear men sheehan uh
thank you for so much for your videos on
nietzsche's genealogy of morals oh
you're very welcome that's that's uh
that's uh nice um glad that they're
helpful for you
text that i've been meaning to get to
for core concept videos
but i i just haven't found the time
sandy do i think the current
distribution of income can be justified
if there's no absolute poverty can
inequality be considered
bad or wrong no the current distribution
of income is
very unjust and not just the current
distribution of income but the current
distribution of wealth
and current distribution of risks it's
incredibly unjust
that's part of why covid did such a
number on the united states
we have been a screwed up nation
basically you know my whole lifetime
once you start actually looking at how
things work
and it's been getting worse and worse
and
[Music]
you know neither political party is
really doing much about it the democrats
at least do
something once in a while the
republicans try to make it you know
worse to their benefit as
as much as possible um
and so you know no there's you can
talk about things being more just or
being more fair
but it's pretty bad right now
um chris gatewood does the unusual
thought process involved in systems
thinking bring challenges to more linear
discourse
have you always gravitate towards system
thinking or systems philosophy
no i i i don't what they call systems
theory that's not what i do
i'm just talking about looking at things
in a systematic way and people have been
doing that for generations without you
know having to like
go and buy books on systems theory or
anything like that
um i i find that a lot of times when
people are denigrating
linear stuff it's usually a caricature
most linear stuff is actually a lot more
dynamic
so all right some of that will you ever
do videos on spinoza
yeah eventually down the line as i
always say when people
are asking questions about that and then
i post my why don't you do videos about
this
anybody who wants to commission me to do
videos on their favorite philosopher
can you know hire me and bankroll the
production of that because
doing videos on this person means i
gotta stop my plans on this person over
here
so you know i'm game to do videos on
anybody i'm competent
to do things on i don't teach spinoza
very often although i have taught
spinoza in the past
in part because i don't i don't find
spinoza as interesting as
as some of the other philosophers who
i'm talking about
but that's you know that's a preference
thing um other people are really into
spinoza if you're
really really super into spinoza you
know you can uh
feel free to get some people together
and i'll
you know shoot some commission videos
all right
um let's see here
so samir asks uh wants to ask two main
questions but
like i said everybody gets one question
am i familiar with the works of medieval
islamic theologians philosophers paulie
math like gazzali
even arabi even cena even rushed
yes i am familiar with them i don't read
arabic so
you know i'm leery about relying heavily
on translations that i can't
you know check stuff on same reason that
i don't do an awful lot of stuff on
chinese philosophy even though i do
teach it
um so yeah
david during can you explain what you
mean when you say you're a pluralist how
does that fit in with being a christian
well you know pluralism means that you
you draw
on different points of view and you
don't think that
any of them are you know absolutely uh
they've got the the market cornered on
truth
depends on what kind of christian you
are i mean if you're like some
you know if you're an evangelical bible
thumper who thinks that like everything
is contained in the bible you know
perspicuity of scripture it's not going
to be compatible with that but
that is actually historically a very
weird aberration
of christianity um not reflected in
in the vast tradition um
you know you could say i'm uh how do how
how does this
pose a problem for me any more than it
does for lactose
or justin martyr or any of these early
christian thinkers
you know i don't i don't see an issue
there
uh marina is there any philosophical
work that addresses eclecticism versus
assimilation
um maybe not in those terms i don't know
that would be a great thing to google
wouldn't it uh
easy enough to find if it does exist but
i would say that you know
um you could look at cicero and read
on the ends and see what he's doing in
that book
by book five it shows you his his sort
of attitude towards these things
um william james another great you know
person to look at about
pluralism itself so yeah
ben best advice for teaching yourself
propositional logic
expect to put in a good bit of time
doing propositional logic
i don't know um so that's something that
that uh i mean i guess i kind of taught
myself
logic years and years and years ago
because i went beyond what my
my class had but i mean i was an
undergraduate then that was
almost 30 years ago and the way that i
do things
usually is not particularly effective
for for others
let's see
ben asks would you say that aquinas's
cinderella cinderace's principle is
necessarily self-evident i wouldn't call
it a principle
i would say that center asus is
something that's within us
according to aquinas and that is
is it necessarily self-evident you want
to read thomas and look at what he says
about
self-evidence because there isn't any
one single meaning to self-evident
um is it self-evident in the sense that
like everybody immediately
intuitively grasps it no obviously not
is it self-evident in that
you know were you to arrive at a better
viewpoint on things looking at the world
looking at yourself
you're probably going to arrive at that
sure but that is that what you call
necessarily
probably not so um but you know i would
i would actually go to the
the discussions on on you know
uh conscience underestimates the natural
law and i'd also look earlier in the
summer where he talks about things being
self-evident like
where he treats is god's existence
self-evident you know persenota
is is the the term in in latin all right
um theogeny is the cynic do you think
it's worth
delving deep into process philosophy do
i consider
it to be a valuable movement um i
i liked reading uh whitehead
and process and reality but that is a
tough tough book so if you're going to
do that
plan to give yourself a lot of time
right
um hartshorn you know i encountered him
mostly
in relation to studying anselm because
hartshorn had like his own version of
the ontological argument
and i haven't read too many other
process philosophers i mean some people
want to say bergstone is a process
philosopher
and i guess you could say he is but
berkshire is really doing his own thing
over here
um i really like bergstone so if if if
you think you know if you're asking
about that i think bergson is well worth
studying
um but it depends on what you're
you're interested in doing um it was a
important movement in philosophy it's
kind of lost
its steam you could say
but that doesn't mean that it's not
worth studying i mean look at how
how much interest there is in let's take
two examples
existentialism and stoicism in the
present right
if you were to say 30 years ago
that stoicism was going to be a big
thing that a lot of people would be
taking seriously and studying
um a lot of people have laughed at you
so lawrence becker was kind of you know
and people like anthony long and chris
gill
uh were sort of voices in the wilderness
you know
um at that time people who were
interested in virtue ethics were mostly
interested in
aristotelian virtue ethics um and you
could say you know like existentialism
by by the time that i was an
undergraduate and then in graduate
school people were like
existentialism is done that's dead you
know we've moved on to other stuff
but now it's back you know people are
reading the existentialists again
so i mean something similar could happen
with process philosophy i i would say
all right um oops just skipped a bit
let's see where we were it was ricky
here we go
[Music]
ricky says i want to say thank you for
helping me understand a political
philosophy course i was in
and to better understand the republic
and the apology well it's great i'm glad
that
i'm glad that you enjoyed that
and that it was helpful for you so
nathan says i watched your video on
yoshihiro
what did he mean by making philosophy
dialogical as opposed to monological is
is similar to boober's idea of ikdu and
s i mean it's similar to bach teen's
ideas that's why he had me reading bach
teen
similar to this is i mean sure it's
similar to boober's idea of
ikdoo and s meaning i i thou
i um it um
but it's so similar to plenty of other
stuff and what did he mean by that i
mean
he meant that in a lot of cases
philosophy is sort of like you talk
at somebody you present somebody with
something and then there's no real back
and forth
um i don't think he's actually right
about that about modern philosophy
there are dialogues in modern philosophy
they're important uh
exchanges that take place some of modern
philosophy even if it seems to be
monological maybe dialogical
i actually think the meditations are
myself but that's a minority view
so yoshihiro was an interesting guy um
he was really quite introverted
he could speak good english but didn't
trust his english
and once he got interested in something
like he'd read everything about it
and uh i can't say that he was actually
a friend as such
but um because there wasn't that that
intimacy
that you need for friendship but
he was something more than just a
acquaintance as well so i don't know
what happened to him
down you know down the road
i don't think we've been in touch for at
least 10 years
um mostly peaceful fascist
are there any politicians that are not
accused of having a cult
seems a natural state of leaders to
ideological followers
yeah that's a silly thing to say there's
i mean if you if you really think
that that uh simply having followers
and being ideological means having a
cult you're using cult in a very
different sense than
when i was talking about the recent
supreme court justice
uh issue right she actually belongs to a
cult
you can just check it out and find that
to be the case
so um and are there politicians who
whose
followers are not simply ideologues yeah
there's plenty of them
i mean there are people who operate in
good faith in politics
and then there's people who are in bad
faith in politics and we need to be able
to distinguish between these
and between nut job ideologues or we're
never going to get out of the situation
that we're in
at present so yeah i i
really ignore this sort of leveling
across the board
kind of stuff as as being non-starters
all right um looks like we have people
who want to argue
that case marina she argued against the
death penalty religion has more leverage
in this than any other pursuit
i don't care if she argued against the
death penalty uh
that's one thing and so you know you can
you
find all sorts of other things where
she's going to be a terrible justice
but you know you think whatever you like
rt whitby do you think plato recognized
the genius of aristotle when he was a
student
good question i i don't know i mean
if he did why didn't he
designate aristotle his successor maybe
maybe he did recognize it but he also
recognized this guy can't fit in here
um it's tough to say when we don't we
don't have enough we don't have enough
reliable
history stuff to tell us what was the
case there
what we do know is that you know
aristotle was an out-of-towner
plato essentially made his nephew
carried out some nepotism literally
nepotism nepose means nephew right
so so plato made his nephew specifics
the next um
skull arc of the academy so yeah
all right um
let me skip down here we go epistemic
epistemic mind is it me or is the lay
public's perception of the discipline of
philosophy heavily influenced by the
continental school it frustrates me
people see philosophies akin to poetry
or literature
it is you the lay public's perception of
the discipline of philosophy
is so vague as to not be associated with
analytic or continental or history of
philosophy schools
the the you know where it would be
different is where they've had some
connection
some exposure to that but most
you know most lay people's conceptions
of philosophy are
overly vague i mean my own family
who are you know my extended family the
lemreese family who are
you know largely blue collar it took
them 10 years to actually realize that i
was not a psychologist
when i was studying philosophy i had to
have those conversations with them
over and over and over again at family
reunions
until finally some of their kids were in
college and were taking philosophy
classes and then they realized that
these are different
different disciplines so yeah all right
um devonnie asked if i'm familiar with
the work of bernard stegler
no i've never read steegler i guess he
died recently
i'm not familiar you know probably 99
of the people who one could ask about
who are contemporary philosophers
um i i probably don't know their work
because there are literally
tens of thousands of philosophers
currently writing
writing books and and all of that so
usually i won't i won't know who they
they are some people have recommended
steegler but kind of busy you know with
the work that i'm currently doing um
john ortiz how is how important is it to
know mathematics
well if you want to balance your
checkbook kind of important you know
personal finance is is one important uh
aspect of that i mean i don't know that
you need to know like linear algebra
to worry about whether you know
shift is going to get your groceries to
you on time or anything like that
mathematics is worth studying and there
is a certain kind of disciplining that
happens with with studying mathematics
that's important
i'm going to tell you a funny story too
little digression
i had a parent teacher conference
yesterday
and my youngest kid
is uh a bit you know very very bright
uh you know in the same way that i think
that i was i was bright and
feeling bored uh not challenged enough
sometimes with the classes
that they're in and uh
anyway no i've never heard you know like
when i was a kid
we would sometimes have here's a great
example so i i've got this uh
this is my textbook for the world
religions class that i'm currently
teaching
so i'd have a textbook right and then
like i put like a comic book inside and
read what i wanted to read or another
book
or something like that and i would i
would screw up in class like that
so my youngest daughter is doing math
in math class but it's not the math that
she was assigned to do in math class
in part because she's bored with the
math that she's supposed to do in math
class
so um you know that's that's that's
quite interesting i never heard of
anybody doing
smuggling in other math to work on so
i saw my other daughter my older
daughter last night and i told her about
this and she said
yeah you know i gave her that algebra
book
because she wanted you know she wanted
to study algebra
and i had some of my old books from
from high school laying around so so i
gave her that one
and i was like oh that's how she did it
so so some people really enjoy math so
much
that they'll go on to to study it uh on
their own
against the rules um in a math class
where they're supposed to be working on
other math
so quite quite a story there how
important is it to know mathematics
it's pretty important you know another
thing i'll say too is people
sometimes say oh i'm just not good at
math well you're not good at math in the
same way that you're not good at playing
guitar
if you want to learn to play guitar
practice playing guitar
right and learn some scales and do the
work if you want to get good at math
put in the work it's not as if we just
have like a night you know native talent
or something like that
a lot of people allow teachers to tell
them that and they
they also tell themselves that when you
know it's just like learning a foreign
language if you want to learn a foreign
language
study the foreign language you know you
want to learn how to dance
go to dance class all right uh
imran says can you kindly say something
about delusion's philosophy how can it
be useful i wonder what use is
philosophy well it's useful to enjoy
studying difficult texts
i'll tell you what one example that i
brought up many times
to clients
duluz has a set of essays called essays
critical and clinical
and in it he's got a discussion of the
billy budd
story by herman melville and in it the
lose does his typical shtick he's like
you know he's going to draw some other
ideas out of this
and one of the things that he he lays
out is about the law
because billy budd is going to be you
know punished
even though he doesn't deserve to be
punished and
the lose notes that the law or moral
norms
can hold back a lot of the wrongdoing
that people do
but the law has to be somewhat brutal in
order to do that
and
it doesn't actually prevent the really
bad people they will still keep on doing
what they're doing they go through it
like you know going through a spider web
but it will hold back a lot of the
middle range jerks
bad people you know uh but it's also
going to
in its dragnet catch up innocent people
and do bad things to them as well and
so this is a great insight
he's using a story to communicate that
we can talk about how policing works
and you know the fact that
many innocent people are often caught up
in dragnets
based on race or class or you know just
geographical area
and so that's a valuable insight and
there's lots of valuable insights like
that in duluth
so it depends on what you want to use
them for
paul laughlin what do i what did i argue
in my doctoral thesis
oh a bunch of different things it was
kind of a mess you know
um that's why i never turned it into a
book it really needed to be like split
into three different things each of
which would be a
book um one was that you know maurice
blondell
was providing an understanding of the
relationship between christianity and
philosophy that was needed today
and that could address contemporary uh
issues and demands um i don't you know i
haven't looked at it for
over 10 years quite frankly um i mean i
defended it in 2002
um so i'd have to actually go back to it
and look at some of those things i was
also really fascinated by using the
untranslated stuff because i could
translate it easily
so you know i was incorporating stuff
from his trilogy and other things but i
i quickly moved on to other
other uh blondel related things
uh adian i'm doing a nietzsche course at
the university of aberdeen i truly
appreciate your content
i know i'm glad that that um it's
helpful for you
uh govind asks would i be interested in
joining discord there's a discord server
called the philosophy chat where we have
weekly readings of the work of hegel
kant
analytic tradition german idealism um i
went on discord
you know by invitation a couple years
ago and
at least the server that i was on just
seemed like a mishmash of people just
like talking
uh past each other and it didn't seem
like a good use of my time
i have to admit i don't really
understand discord or why
what i would be doing with it or what i
would be using it for
somebody would have to like walk me
through it and make a case for
why given all the other things that i do
why it would be a good use of my time
rather than spending that time shooting
videos doing podcast stuff meeting with
clients who pay me
teaching classes
you know offering the other kinds of
online events like this that i'm doing
right now so i don't know i don't know
enough about discord to say
all right all right
marseille what do i dislike about the
stoics
um i think that you know some of the
cultural assumptions that they make
probably need to be left behind
i think that that despite talking about
the social nature
of human beings that there's there's a
bit too much focus on
um the individual and there needs to be
more on relationships and how we
we foster each other but this is the
sort of stuff that like you know
contemporary
stoics just like neo-aristotelians can
um
rebuild into it you know i mean
traditions are
living through finding these these
pain points and then then improving on
them so
um let's see
jason says uh
what do i think william james has to
offer both philosophy and psychology
today
do i think religious experience is due
for a comeback in our society or just a
relic of the past religious experience
never went away
so i don't know why it would have a
comeback people have been reporting
religious experiences continually
and what do i think william james has to
offer both philosophy and psychology
i mean the pragmatic method discussion
stuff is pretty
important the will to believe that's why
i teach that in my intro to philosophy
classes is a great essay as well
and you know his his discussions of the
emotions
i think has some some useful things to
provide us i don't fully agree with the
way he
structures stuff but i think there's
some valuable insights there
um i mean when it comes to psychologists
i'd have to have psychologists weigh in
on that
probably but i
i really enjoyed james
then again you know i've been reading
him for quite a long time
by the way james had a connection with
maurice blondell
james viewed blondel as a pragmatist
and blondel was cool with that until he
found out what james
meant by pragmatist and then he was like
yeah don't call me a pragmatist i'm all
about action i'm all about you know
figuring out how how things develop
outside of the world of pure thought
in practical activity but i'm not a
pragmatist like you
and one of the things that's kind of
cool is uh
blondel's oxyo 1893 sold out
very quickly and james wanted to read
the book
so james wrote him and said hey do you
have any extra copies
blondel sent james his last remaining
copy
and said hey don't lose this i'm going
to need it back
that was the gen how generous this guy
was
uh james you know read it and you know
thought it was quite interesting then
sent it back then found out that he had
the author's only original copy so
that's kind of cool
all right um
let's see
gil gosh i know you're mostly a scholar
of western philosophy who do you like to
read as far as eastern philosophy is
concerned
i mean when i have the time which is not
always
i you know i like teaching world
religions because it always gives me a
chance to go
back and like read you know various
buddhist works
and the dao zhang again and you know
other taoist literature like the drung
zoo
you know i i'll teach you actually
sometimes in
intro to philosophy class the uh the
menchus and
and sometimes the analects um
and you know i i find this stuff
interesting to check
out and to read through um
but like i said i'm kind of handicapped
i don't
i don't have the facility with the
languages
and that for me kind of sucks because
because i know how important it is to be
able to
to read things in the original if if i
want to if i want to go back to things
um so yeah it's sort of a wide
smattering i mean i
my interests are very diverse you know i
i i
i like teaching stuff in religious
studies because it lets me look at like
entire world
views of civilizations and do a lot of
comparative work
so
all right um
mark asks how would hegel interpret this
point in history with covet versus
neopian and relu reference to freedom
i'm not sure what neopian is
um i mean hegel eagle would look at
as the world is america's failed
response to covid
which lar you know it's really happening
for
four main reasons one is things were
shitty before copen
our healthcare system is not a system
it's been a mess for years and years and
years
many inequalities and all sorts of
inefficiencies in it
we're the only developed nation that
doesn't have uh state provided health
care as we should
and it's because of the second thing
which is a highly ideological
conception of freedom that stresses
personal liberties
and whatever you know the republican
party has picked up lately
uh and run with as what real freedom is
and from a hegelian perspective that is
just foolish nonsense
um and and really from most most other
perspectives of freedom
got into an interesting thing you know
with one of my conservative
uh friends uh and colleagues where he
was like what freedoms have we lost
under under you know covet and he's
thinking like freedom to travel
he doesn't want to wear a mask stuff
like that and i was like the freedom not
to freaking die
from some jerk-offs who you know think
that they ought to like
walk around do whatever the hell they
want and infect people
i mean the freedom to actually live kind
of a big freedom
you know i'm i'm sort of like a uh
rooseveltian four
freedoms guy freedom from fear is an
important freedom right
and these these like personal liberty
people
they think that that their freedom is
like
the the one that matters most and they
ignore everything else so that's the
second major
issue the third is that we don't have a
system you know
we don't actually have a health care
system we have all these different
states each of which have their own
exchanges there's people who don't fit
into them
we have medicaid we have medicare we
have all these private insurance
companies that are primarily just
interested in making money they don't
care about
human lives very much or quality of life
and that this has been allowed to be the
case and and again both parties
bear blame for that right um
particularly centrist democrats but the
republicans have been much worse on that
in the last 20 years from from what i've
seen
and then the last thing was a total
failure of leadership
on the federal level and on many state
levels
where like for example here in wisconsin
uh our do nothing republicans have
have you know because of gerrymandering
they have more power than they should
and the wisconsin
supreme court has more conservatives
than it should
and our governor's reasonable mass
mandate was struck down
uh people playing politics with people's
lives right so hegel would look at that
and he'd be like wow this is
irrationality
on irrationality and irrationality this
is a failed culture
a failed state and that's the way a lot
of people worldwide are looking at us
and rightly so you know this may be this
is i mean
for everybody who's like oh you know
america has to stay number one and all
that
you want america to stay number one
enact universal health care
that would be like a major thing that
you could do get over your qualms
whatever ideological bugaboos you've got
you know there's whispering in your ear
this
isn't freedom and just enact it like
reasonable people
and then you have a shot at like holding
on to our current position
if that's really what matters to you
otherwise
forget it it ain't gonna happen you know
um oop just hear my
my cat crying um
where is she
sassy cat is almost 18 years old and
i'm not quite sure where she is or what
she's what she's crying for
hopefully she's not stuck somewhere like
she's she's found herself occasionally
being stuck on the uh uh
table let me let me just go check out it
we're super super quick
oh there you are
okay
yep that was her here she is
my little 18 year old well almost 18
she'll be 18 in november
i think she's getting a little bit uh
senile because she's getting on a table
and not being sure quite how to get down
from it and
yelling like you heard her doing so
she is the last of our our four-legged
family
we're getting by the way a carrier so i
can like take her on walks with her
cuddled up
sort of like this with me all right let
me get back to questions
um let's see here
uh team angio what are your thoughts on
jordan peterson and people unfamiliar
with philosophy as a whole like stephen
hicks
and sam harris talking about the field
so poorly well i mean
stephen hicks is actually a philosopher
i know the guy he's he's brought me down
to rockford university
although not lately i think he heard me
saying bad stuff about about his book
um and you know so he's a randian um
pretty hardcore randian and important in
those circles
his book on post-modernism is just
garbage and peterson relied on it
and and so you know that's why you you
actually got to know the texts that
you're studying
i mean peterson to talk about that thing
so
he goes to talk about communism and then
admits he hasn't actually
read anything other than the communist
manifesto
that's pretty pitiful pretty pathetic um
you know if you've ever read his maps of
the mind
not a great book um i haven't read his
12 rules but
there's an awful lot of people who
really glom
on to these uh types
and they're like oh have you read this
person have you read this person oh it's
so awesome
and you're like i don't know i'm going
to spend the time on reading that
but then when you do you're like oh this
is this is i mean what's good in this is
already over in these people
and the rest of it's all garbage so not
a big fan of peterson um
and uh you know i don't have to be i
guess
um let's see
oh here's an interesting comment from
mcc i grew up in colorado in the 80s and
70s
it's the same thing with respect to
skiing no middle class or poor native
coloradans skied then too expensive
yeah i mean you can still ski in
colorado because global warming
hasn't met that you you don't get enough
snow
the way that is the case here
unfortunately in wisconsin
um but yeah it's it there's a lot of
class distinctions like that
all right um let's see who haven't i
taken a question from
we're getting close to time too
um
[Music]
max lawton here's a good question at
what point do you think clarity of style
becomes an unnecessary impediment to
understanding philosophy
did heidegger and hegel have to write
the way they did in order to communicate
their ideas
i would say you could say that heidegger
and and hegel could be more clear but
yeah you can't you you can't there's a
way of making things clear that actually
makes them less clear because you're no
longer talking about the same thing
this is a big big problem in analytic
philosophy
where you know and also in in you know
among a lot of historians of
their class sassy among a lot of
historians of philosophy where
they oversimplify and they
get things wrong you know it's sort of
like with occam's razor occam's razor is
not
you know the simpler explanation is the
best explanation it is entities are not
to be multiplied beyond
necessity are those exactly the same
thing no
and in order to understand what do you
mean entities are not to be multiplied
beyond necessity
well you got to you know think things
through a bit right uh but it becomes
more clear when you think okay so if
there's like
16 principles that i need in order to
make make
sense out of this phenomenon i shouldn't
um you know deal with 26 instead but you
also shouldn't deal with
with eight and so you can say something
similar
kind of analogously on lexical lines
um you're probably not going to be able
to teach hegel sufficiently
by trying to make it simpler than it is
maybe i've done that i don't know maybe
maybe my videos have oversimplified
hegel as well um
let's see here
[Music]
daniel asks i'm interested in comparing
aristotle's virtue ethics with eastern
philosophy what do i think about their
social conventions
whose social conventions eastern
philosophy i mean
there is no such thing as eastern
philosophy to begin with there is
chinese philosophy which is its own
vast cultural sphere with multiple
massive traditions that change over time
there and then influences like japanese
philosophy and korean philosophy
so we can talk about the entire you know
east asian cultural sphere
then there's the uh you know indian
subcontinent with its own
whole thing right and then we've got
um you know various indigenous
philosophies which often are you know
considerable sophistication and then
we've got the whole
field of islamic thought so
there's no such thing as eastern
philosophy i would say look for things
that
that if you want to do comparative work
look for things that are kind of similar
to
what it is that you want to talk about
so like when it comes to virtue ethics
the thing that people usually do is
aristotle and confucius right
um or aristotle and uh
you know some stuff from the the uh
arthashastra you know um but you get you
gotta go
you kind of dig in and and find where
you think the similarities are gonna be
and then then i guess you can do
something with it
um let's see who else we got
zeno asks one of our thoughts on the
existentialist
would you consider nietzsche an
existentialist or something different
so i mean i've got a couple videos
specifically on this
i think existentialism is a broad tent
that a lot of figures fit into and
there's no one single definition of it
and people who try to give one single
definition of it are either
like sart trying to bogart the whole
field to themselves
or they're oversimplifying or they
just don't know what they're doing um
and often take their lead from start
then
existentialism is the philosophy that
means that existence precedes essence
well that's not everybody and nietzsche
is solidly within the existentialist
sphere
um lev shestoff who i've been releasing
videos on
is one of the people who clearly
identified he was the second generation
existentialist
he clearly identified the connections
between nietzsche and these other
existentialist
thinkers and so you know
there is no one single definition but
there are key themes
that you can point at and again i've
done a couple videos
on that so you might want to take a look
at those let me scroll down
we're getting close to the end of our
our time
let me see if there's anything
particularly compelling
uh here's a good one from chris beltran
have i ever participated in
philosophy-based debates i'm a big fan
of the old intelligence squared oxford
style debates we'd love to hear you
participate in something like that um
i don't think that um debates are
usually
that that that useful you could have
somebody who's worth debating with
and you're gonna have some pretty clear
lines about what you're gonna do i
prefer
dialogues and discussions um i don't
like
discussing things with people who aren't
in good faith uh
it's not usually worth my time that said
if somebody wants me to do debates they
can pay me to do that
so instead me taking time away from my
other endeavors and doing something that
i normally
wouldn't do i don't think that you're
going to see um
you know ox intelligence squared calling
me up because i'm not a big name in
philosophy right
and i'm not like teaching at important
schools where
where most of their chums come from so
that probably won't be be an issue
all right uh let's see if we can take
one more
thing um
um i was reading something about do i
have a good chair for reading
i mean i got i read in a bunch of
different chairs
uh okay
so here's a good one to go out on from
sunny
i've been trying to learn more about
philosophy for a while and it's one of
my biggest
interests why do i feel like i don't
truly understand or
learn so that is a
that is a common experience i go through
that myself every once in a while where
i'm like
man i just i i'm not getting it you know
um and i'll tell you there are times
when i i
get in front of that chalkboard and i've
filled it up with stuff like for the
half hour hegel videos
this is sometimes the issue and i've
like read and reread the passages i'm
going to talk about
you know a couple times and you know
i've been reading hegel now for
25 years in a serious way
and sometimes i'll get up there and i'm
ready to shoot and i'm like
man i can't remember what the hell i was
going to talk about i look at the board
and i'm like
this kind of makes sense and then i'm
like well i'm not shooting today
um that happens that's okay that's
that's a
you know you can't be like on all the
time
and you know if you feel like you're not
grasping the totality of a philosopher's
work
that's okay you don't necessarily have
to in order for what you're grasping to
be valuable
if you are reading say seneca for
example right seneca wrote a lot
let's say you read through one of his
biggest works the moral letters or
letters to achilles
and you get some stuff out of it uh and
other things are confusing to you
and you kind of see how things hold
together but not not completely and you
and you can't like answer questions like
what would seneca say about this
you still have accomplished what you've
accomplished you still do know
something it's not like a complete void
and the other thing i'll say too is
don't measure yourself against sort of
the best performances
that other people are doing when you see
somebody doing
a talk or you know when you see one of
my lecture videos
i've been prepping for that
for for a while right and if i
don't like the take that i do i will get
rid of that i've edited it right
i i often begin videos
with every once in a while one of them
gets in there where i'm like i start out
and i'm like
today you know we're going to talk about
unamuno's tragic sense of life and you
know what he thought about philosophy
and
and i'll i'll get to the point where i'm
like no that's not right
i cut that off and you're not seeing
that and when you're reading other
people's books
you know like cicero's uh academia or
you know on the nature of the gods
you're getting the finished product
don't don't
measure your own thinking and work
against that finished product even with
anti-systematic thinkers like nietzsche
or shustoff
you are still getting a finished product
that was edited
so you know you you may still
well you'll always even if you're like
the most accomplished thinker you're
still going to have more stuff to learn
but um don't be so hard on yourself
don't downgrade the things that you
you do know about the texts thinkers
topics that you've been studying so all
right it's 133
i got to get something to eat uh and
check on the sassy cat and
get ready for my patreon exclusive
philosophy chat that i'll be doing
so thanks for all the questions um got a
lot of cool stuff coming up this month
if you haven't seen the update video
you probably want to check it out a lot
of online events
uh coming up this month because of you
know stoicon stoic on x
stoic week all of that have my worlds of
speculative fiction of course and the
classic heavy metal class and all those
other things
so you may want to check those things
out
hope that wherever you are in the world
you're having a good morning
evening afternoon here
might be middle of the night for those
of you who are like in australia
or japan so i'll see all of you next
time around